[Music]
what's up with the picture
that
is a 70-75 bmw csl
king of beauty say you're back 135k
i'm saving up
gonna get one how's that going for you
considering you just got fired had a
couple g saved
only another 133 000 to go
[Music]
i know a guy
nath clark him and his crib and about 14
stick ups he's slick
he's the fourth man
collection
never done a robbery before
[Music]
if you don't know why you're doing this
then you need to get out the car robbing
a bank
you know that's mad right honey yeah
because it's a police fact
what is he talking about i'm doing this
job it's suicide just think about it man
use your head
[Music]
i'm in
can i trust you
four things you need for the artist
still
set up where you gonna hit him when
swell mob two to four no more
guns low to the blanks doesn't matter
people see guns they automatically think
death the getaway car ain't always
messing around messing around either
going to the big house or
getting lit up
right
[Music]
free advice
he's playing in the bank goes wrong
you're probably gonna have to kill
somebody to get out
security guard woman
maybe even a kid
are you 12 i'm 16. don't
you are flinch
junior you shot him they're trying to
keep him alive right now if he dies i'm
going to kill him you're scared
and killed
did you come here to be a murderer i
thought you came here to rob a fact you
got to be in this do you really want to
kill a little girl
man all i really want is to buy a 70 to
75 bmw csl 3.0 and drive away from here
forever well god damn
[Music]
[Music]
you